so we had a guest not only canceled on
us last minute today but do it in the
rudest way that we've ever experienced
hurling abuse at producer Pat you maybe
someday I will tell the story about what
happened today but it is crazy but the
situation we find ourselves in is that
we were planning on using that interview
today and now we don't have it and we're
not on a deadline so because so many
people are always hoping to call in we
are opening up the phone lines at 6 1 7
8 3 0 47 50 let's see what is on
people's minds today briefly let's go to
mark from Newport mark from Newport we
haven't heard from for a while what's
going on mark who David so I had
actually posted about this on your
subreddit but I wanted to try to dig a
little deeper over the phone as possible
so you had mentioned that as opposed to
Elizabeth Warren's wealth tax you had
preferred alterations in the way capital
gains are taxed as a means to tax
accumulated capital so as a financial
advisor that actor seems like an
inefficient way to tax accumulated
capital which I really want to so I was
just curious what am I missing
well how would you like to tax it I
would prefer something along the lines
of Elizabeth Warren's wealth tax just
because there's not as many ways that
people like me are required to basically
help people avoid that tax if you read
into her proposal it's pretty much just
every dollar over 50 million armed with
nothing really excluded now I would be
open to the conversation of excluding
certain types of assets from that were
forced to draw assets maybe avoiding
them from other types of taxation or I
don't know I'm open to that conversation
but I just as I think as a meze as to
have a broader tax base to bring in more
revenue and just to to limit wealth
inequality I think there's less room for
people like me to help people avoid
paying taxes yeah I mean I think that
you
have to balance every single one of
these proposals with the path to making
it a reality and a number of what seemed
to be like pretty good legal analyses
that I've read say that passing a wealth
tax like what she is proposing whether
or not you exclude certain types of
assets would be extraordinarily
difficult and it could take a decade
while it's hung up in courts so I think
there's simpler things that could be
done that would be legally less complex
in order to raise revenue I mean one of
them is and this is usually thought of
merely in terms of the context of Social
Security's viability but you could raise
the income cap on Social Security from
whatever it is now a hundred and twenty
three thousand I believe to something
higher than that you don't have to put
any new infrastructure in place you're
literally just changing the number by a
different amount than you would by
inflation alone and you immediately
generate significantly more revenue when
it comes to capital gains you are right
that there are whole industries built
around helping people avoid capital
gains but there are also changes that
can be made at the most drastic which
would have a lot of opposition would be
taxing capital gains at the same rate as
one's wage would be taxed based on their
income um that would be but you think
really you realize the game I'm sorry
what was that
oh I'm sorry interrupt you still get to
choose when you realize the game and
then you can still like orient your
investment allocation to there's no
question about it it's not a silver
bullet right sure but I think that when
we think you're thinking about all the
right stuff I think that the problem
what we should really think about even
if we like the wealth tax in principle
is the reality that legislatively it
would be extremely difficult that's not
a reason not to think about it it's not
a reason not to do it I just think there
may be lower hanging fruit but it sounds
like you're thinking along the same
lines yeah the bottom line is that is
accumulated capital needs to be taxed so
whatever can get passed alright mark
great to hear from you mark from Newport
I was now down the road from you
Narragansett over the weekend oh no way
I lived there when I was in school yeah
you know I didn't love it I have to
admit I didn't it wasn't like the best
place but it was a
good weekend alright mark great to hear
from you appreciate the call